so if you're allergic to dogs go away
for your own safety
come here okay okay
this is dog his name is Richie
maybe he'll play a game of chess wanna
play chess
I'll play chess no he just wants carrots
sorry if if this is loud you want to
play me maybe we can play someone let's
play someone I just want a quick game
let's play this guy efox tangled all
right I'm gonna play this and we're
gonna have a Stafford gambit
I don't know if I have a dog emotes
there is a twitch dog emotes but there's
not an e mode of this dog have to make
an emote of this dog all right so my
opponent declines the gambit and now
it's just equal material so this should
be very a simple development for luck
this is three O rated blitz also thanks
wick
what's your name like X for the sub even
my dog is thinking you okay now the
challenge is seeing the position around
my dog let's castle let's play rook e8 I
did a stream about a year ago was called
streaming with a pug and it got like the
lowest number of views of like any of my
videos on YouTube I think it only has
like 200 views but it was playing chess
while being distracted by a pug okay
let's play Bishop f5 and I just want to
align with the Queen and do something I
can't even see what I'm drawing but
hopefully these no they don't make any
sense I'm threatening Knight g3 so I
attack the Queen don't you on this is
exciting
let's play do I want to play let's play
Queen here I'm stacking either pawn
and I think I'm threatening to take on
d2 I can draw the arrow whoa
takes a pawn which is like surrounded by
pieces there's no way that's good what
to do I could play go take on d2 maybe
let's play Bishop g6 first okay I think
the dog has had enough
can I go be right back
[Music]
most amazing tactic ever okay slow
motion checkmates GG cannot believe my
dog like walked out right before the
most amazing finale that was nice